Est-ce qu'on va le voir?
Dites-moi bonjour.
- Bonjour.
- Et voilà.
Est-ce que ces costauds pour
faire face aux défis du monde de
l'immobilier.
- Il y a quelque chose
d'important dans le budget
annoncé aujourd'hui, il y a
quand même plusieurs points sont
des points de surcts de surcts e
marché présentement.
- Ce qui est paradoxal, on parle
aud, mais on veut aider
les gens à acheter une maison.
y, jusqu'à 40 000 $,
8000 par année comprimée dedans.
Retrait non imposable,contrairÉa
semble, passez-moi l'expression,
une petite merveille, au cours
des 34 prochaines années.
- Ce qui est ciblé, ce sont les
nouveaux acheteurs, c'est rentré
dans le marché qui est très
complexe.
La mesure du CELI, on peut
épargner dans le but d'achet
une première maison, ça touche
peu de monde en réalité, il y a
déjà beaucoup de propriétaires.
On vit seulement ceux qui vont
passer de un à l'autre.
Disant un privilène
que les Canadiens en rond.
- Crise du logement, on en a
déjà parlé ensemble, on ne
construit plus d'immeubXes@
logements, hier on parlait...
contenu des coûts de
construction.
4 000 000 sur 5 ans, est-ce que
c'est un objectif réalisable.
- Le recrutement de la main-d'o,
les coûts des matériaux sont
très chers, les terrains sont
rares, restrictions municipales,
c'est sont beaucoup de
conditions qui font la hausse
des coûts de construction des
logements dans les dernières
années.
Même si le gouvernement veut
injecter de l'argent, il va
faire face a ces obstacles.
- Mais ça aide?
- Ça aide, il n'y a pas assez
largement, ce qui n'est pas
faux, donc il faut accélérer
rythme de production des
logements.
On essaie d'insérer des fonds
publics pour faire en sorte que
le gouvernement soit un
partenaire dans la production
des logements plutôt qu'un
obstacle réglement
Ça facilite la construction de
logements, oui il va y avoir un
impact s........
100 000  ça peut
paraître beaucoup sur cinq ans,
mais je pense que le NPD
demandait 1 million de logements
sur cinq ans.
Ça peut être peu aussi.
- 100 000 dilués sur l'ensemble
de la province, si on est
capable de donner un choc dans
l'offre, en accélérantrapidemenn
laps de temps très court, ça
peut faire une différence.
- La spéculation immobilière qui
est au vu de plusieurs un
cancers qui fêtent monter les
prix, cette restriction aux
ordres acheteurs étrangers pour
une période de deux ans, est-ce
que ça va fonctionner, est-ce
que ça va enlever des joueurs au
marché?
Apaiser le marché si je peux
dire?
- Ça va affecter certains
marchés dans certains endroits
dans cer
propriété, les acheteurs
étrangers sont concentrés dans
les grandes villes, dans le type
condos, on n'en trouve beaucoup
avant-coonto,
peu à Montréal.
Plus cette mesure va avoir un
arce qu'on va
venir réduire la demande qu'on
a, ça va venir ralentir
l'augmentation des prix, mais
dans un marché comme Montréal,
où les gens qui ce magazine des
maisons en banlieue de Montréal,
on aura probablement pas le mêmt
très peu...
- la revente à l'intérieur de 12
mois, pour parler clairement, ce
sont ceux qui font des "flips"
on les vise en disant, on va les
taxer.Expliquez-moi ce que ça vt
faire?
- Quand c'est la maison
principale évidemment il y a
moyen d'échanger la maison
principale.
- Il y a des gens qui jouent
avec ça.
- Des transactions sur les 12
mois, je n'ai pas de facture, je
suis étonné que ce
phénomène répandu.
Je pense que c'est une mesure
qui aura beaucoup moins d'impact
parce qu'on cible des
transactions qui doiotent avoir
lieu dans certains endroits,
mais ctiquetiquetiquetiquetiquee
problème généralisé.
- C'est peut-être pour faire
face à un problème médiatisé,
certains "flips" des gens qui
ont fait beaucoup d'argent.
On s'en souvient la crise du
logement, on ne parlait que de
ça, les loyers restent
extrêmement chers pour certains
région de Montréal.
- Le gouvernement n'a pas
beaucoup d'outils, car j'ai dits
qu'il met en place, j'avais
essayé de mettre des mesures
dans toutes les stades que jepe.
Le gouvernement fédéral est
quand même limité dans la
production de logements, puisque
l'aménagement du territoire émis
en place par le municipal.
On veut mettre des logements sur
le marché, et j'av
très fort, mais si les
gouvernements provinciaux et
municipalités rega
bras croisés, ça réserva moins
les pactes.
Pourquoi fournir ces logements,
il faut trouver les espaces pour
les faire.
Beaucoup de quartiers sont
projetés et sur la
densification, pour qu'on ne
logement.
On ne transforme pas le bâti que
les gens connaissent.
construction ce n'est pas une
bonne idée.
Il y a beaucoup de citoyens quiu
sable dans l'engrenage du
gouvernement fédéral.
Ces acteurs jouent beaucoup plus
haut niveau municipal que
provincial.
Les municipalités ne sont pas
nécessairement tous les
partenaires de la construction
de plus de logements dans leur
communauté.
- Ont laissé, on ne peut pas
échapper une certaine
densification, parce que sin